more
shanks that's basically all that i
needed for this to be legendary and yet
oda sensei has given us so so much more
a ton of lore about the country of wano
the void century the ancient weapons and
even the one piece and a lot more green
ball who i think has established himself
as a fantastic antagonist in just a few
scenes again it's really hard to decide
where to start so i'll go with shanks
and green ball first and then dissect
all the incredible information we've
gotten from the secret chamber under the
surface of wanos lake now i really
wasn't sure where oda was going with
yokogi's fight against momo but it turns
out that in the end it was a classic
admiral introduction aramaki shows up
gives us a full load of his unique
personality and shows us just how
ridiculously powerful he is as a fighter
and then before he can show us the
extent of his true powers the fight is
cut short and teases a major fight
towards the end of the story you'll
probably remember that odacensa
introduced all of the admirals in
exactly the same way first we had aokiji
who showed that he was kind and
compassionate towards the crew giving
them a taste of his power yes because he
is after all a marine admiral but in the
end avoiding any serious harm towards
luffy and robin sparing them and even
giving them some advice before freezing
over an entire ocean and so we do know
what type of personal kiji is and what
he's capable of but it's way too early
for any straw hat to fight on his level
including of course luffy next we have
kizaru he arrives on sabah odi with his
lazy but surprisingly sharp attitude we
immediately understand that he is way
more merciless than aokiji but also
doesn't carry the same anger and
ambition as a kainu does he has an
admittedly fantastic sense of humor and
demonstrates his powers by taking out
all of the assembled supernova and straw
hats who only get away in the end thanks
to rayleigh somehow interfering again we
don't really know what kizaru looks like
when he's actually going all out a kainu
gets a two-fold introduction we see how
cold-hearted and radical he is in the
ohara flashback which is then only
driven home by his actions at
marinefords he takes out his own men for
not fighting takes out ace in front of
luffy's eye by taunting him and has no
intention at all to spare the life of
any of the pirates there even if it
means hundreds of unnecessary marines
die this time it's shanks intervening
who keeps a kainu from unleashing hell
and in general i think the fact that the
war took place at marine headquarters
limited all three of the admirals in how
crazy they could actually get with their
attacks because i think all of them very
much looked capable of continuing the
fight or even stepping it up from there
on dressrosa we are then introduced to
fujitora again we quickly get the sense
of his unique personality he's similar
to kizaru in his readiness to attack on
a large scale very emotional like a
kainu but overall seems to be a good and
very compassionate person like aokiji
that really wants the best for the
people of the world he easily is the
most scary fighter in the stand of
window flamingo in law lets himself get
stalled by sabo and gives us a hint for
how powerful he actually is at the end
of the arc when he effortlessly lifts
the rubble of the entire island of the
grounds and so i'd argue that this
introduction of green bull followed the
exact same pattern ryokugyu is extremely
violent and merciless like a kainu and
has his own share of hardcore radical
ideas about how the world works i mean
he goes full world government supremacy
and looks down on his opponents here
however while akainu is a crazy idealist
dedicated to his ideal of absolute
justice where he as an individual
doesn't matter that much aramaki came to
wano in the first place to prove himself
and get a well done from his boss he is
very well aware that the government is
flawed but doesn't really seem to care
that much unlike fujitora for example
and once the stakes became too high in
other words when sheng sent him the most
awesome and amazing warning of all time
he decided that it's not really worth
the hassle after all and decides to
leave by the way i really love how oda
sensei is playing admiral and yonko fans
against each other all the time i think
aramaki here expresses pretty clearly
that he sees himself strong enough to be
able to fight with shanks but given that
he's alone surrounded by enemies
probably came to the realization that
being caught between two yonko crews and
powerful samurai might not be the
smartest move a very smart move by the
way subscribing to this channel i think
the fact that he stops the fight right
here is very similar to kizaru and ben
batman at marineford not exactly scared
but very well aware that it would be a
fight that they have to go all out on
and that they might very well lose and
so other than aokiji who believes in
fairness or kainu who just wants to be
seen as strong and consequence greenball
doesn't really seem to care how he's
perceived or whether he's perceived as a
coward he's just in it for himself it
seems though i still think that there is
a real chance that aramaki just like
fujitora has a hidden agenda something
that oda sensei has hinted at before in
an sbs and just like the other admiral's
introduction power-wise hideyokugyu also
gives us an impressive tease of what
he's actually capable the fact that he
makes fun of rhizo for thinking that his
forest powers would have such an obvious
weakness like fire is exactly the type
of meta commentary that i personally
love it's just a super self-aware joke
and i love that aramaki isn't
automatically inferior to a kainu just
because he's woods and a kind with fire
it makes his powers even more awesome
somehow than they already are and even
though yamato and momo lands some
serious hits on him it seems really
obvious that aramaki isn't even serious
yet at this point and so with all the
admirals now fully introduced i think
the next time we will see them all
together will be when we finally get to
see all of them use their full power and
go all out in other words all of them
will change the landscape forever aokiji
and the kaino have given us a taste of
that on punk hazards ryokugyu has shown
us how he changes the entire landscape
of mono passively and kizaru's light
powers might very well be the secret
behind anna's lobby's eternal day as for
fujitora i have honestly no idea in what
crazy way his fruit might change the
environment around him maybe it was the
gravity fruit that built the redline who
knows i've also heard the theory that
it's actually not fujitora himself who
ate the gravity fruit but his sword that
he always uses to produce his powers and
now if that were true maybe fujitora has
eaten yet another logia fruit that we're
not even aware of yet by the way this
just popped into my head but in theory
shanks could also be wielding a devil
fruit power without having eaten a fruit
himself if his sword griffin was infused
with a devil fruit as well
that would be truly wild then again as
he demonstrates quite nicely here shanks
probably doesn't need a devil fruit
power to be one of the most feared men
in one piece i mean i really think that
any scene that we get with shanks should
be celebrated whenever this man appears
the tights of the story of one piece
shift and major things start to happen
not only did shanks just basically
announce the race for the one piece
between the four yonko but he also made
some serious statements of power and
character here now i do think that some
people were annoyed that shanks
seemingly only has appeared in wano to
promote his upcoming movie that i by the
way can't wait to buy the tickets for
here in japan and honestly i think it
would be naive to think that the timing
of all this is just mere coincidence
having two chapters with shanks right
before the movie drops however i highly
doubt that oda sensei just threw shanks
one of his key characters that he barely
shows to us into that mix to promote a
non-canon movie i do think however that
the ending of wano and the battle
between luffy and kaido was purposefully
cut short at some point to accommodate
shanks's appearance in time for the
movie which isn't terrible but still
somewhat sad i would say also when
shanks talks about the new generation
that is changing the world he thinks
about luffy momo hiyori and a mysterious
small silhouette that does look
suspiciously like uttar from the new
movie i don't really have a problem with
throwing her in here as a little easter
egg or with the fact that this might
make utta somewhat canon similarly to
how shiki is from strong worlds however
i'm not a giant fan of mixing canon with
non-canon stuff just to drive sales for
movie tickets i mean i'm already excited
about the movie as is no need for that i
think but with that being addressed
shanks very much does have a purpose for
being here at wano's borders holy usopp
so much stuff happening really makes me
hungry so good thing i just got my boxer
this month in case you don't know this
is a monthly snack box subscription
service that assembles all types of
fantastic japanese tea pairings snacks
and sweets from all across japan and
sends it to wherever you may live and
because every new boxu has its very own
theme there is always a ton of new
snacks and tastes to try out and it
literally always tastes amazing this
month's boxu is themed onsen vacation
onsen being the japanese word for hot
spring and so it has stuff from some of
my favorite places in japan where i've
actually gone to for beyonce like this
mount fuji black tea from hakone or this
really awesome looking black chocolate
strawberry from nagano if you still
haven't tried them out you really should
and you can use my code ohara and the
link in the description to get 15 off
first of all i'm really happy to see
that as i explained in detail in my
luffy and shanks video this week shanks
most likely isn't a bad guy it sounded
like he actively decided to come to wano
in anticipation of someone like green
bull coming after luffy and co while
they're still trying to recover from the
fights i do think that this would also
fit in wonderfully with shanks stopping
the war to save luffy and every other
time he basically has watched over him
yes who knows maybe he also got his hand
on the road poneglyph we see later in
the chapter as well but i think that
shanks's reaction and dialogue here
strongly suggests that he came to watch
over luffy's recovery and that hockey
burst he shows us there is just next
level hype i hope i'm not the only one
that's relieved to see that there is a
lot more to the strongest form of hockey
than we've already seen we went from
knocking out weak-minded people to
taming animals then using it for battle
and coding yourself in it and now all
the way to launching controlled wide
range attacks on a strong enemy you do
realize that shanks's haki is so
powerful he located green ball picked
him out of all the people on one right
now and then directed his anger and
warning to him paralyzing and scaring an
admiral and as for how it works i don't
think this is telepathy as much as it's
just projecting one's will just how
characters can sense bloodlust for
example shanks's haki oozes his emotions
and will i kinda like to think about
this as an inversion to luffy's voice of
all things luffy is so fine-tuned with
his observation haki that he can tell
exactly what a person's true intentions
and emotions are and shank seems to do
the opposite making his intentions clear
to anyone he chooses to target and that
just makes me incredibly excited
especially because it plays into the
idea that luffy will still have to learn
a lot of stuff from shanks before he can
face the final big baddies of the story
that by the way i have a video for you
as well there is still more to devil
fruits and to haki that can be mastered
and of course luffy's reaction to shanks
is just pure gold i also love that he
jinbe and zorro were ready to jump in
and help momo at any moment of course
they would know something was going on
and really it is such a cool group of
the straw hats top fighters excluding of
course yamato who is already with momo
the straw hats at this point are just a
real crew of monsters and i can't wait
to see everyone's bounties soon but now
let's finally talk about the crazy lore
drop that we got this chapter robin and
law are taken to a secret passageway by
the former shogun of mono and odin's
father tsukiaki who had been living in
hiding after being captured and his
son's death by the way in case you were
wondering why he's here as i explained
in his character analysis law is
interested in the poner glyphs because
corazon and in a way i guess also
sengoku motivated him to find out the
truth about his d heritage something
that law is kind of obsessed with now
this secret passageway leads into a
secret little chamber containing wano's
road poneglyph that we had been looking
for throughout the entire arc and even
though sukiyaki never spilled the
existence of this room to kaido to shave
for that the yonko still find out
anyways thanks to jack and that's
because as it turns out jack is actually
a fishman as we've been speculating
that's how he survived being sunken by
sengoku and fujitora for instance now
this is relevant of course because the
chamber is below the sea level of the
artificial lake around wano and so that
means that jack most likely found it
diving around wano which brings back a
very interesting question
can jack actually still swim clearly he
can breathe underwater as a fisherman
but can he move because how did he
explore the waters around wano and how
did he escape from the bottom of the
ocean
very mysterious and what that means is
that the straw heads right now are
officially in possession of three road
poneglyphs the one on zou the robbing of
big moms and this one the only one
missing is the one from fishman island
most likely in the possession of shanks
as i explained in this video right here
that's a pretty big deal i would say but
what's even more fascinating is that we
see an entire ancient city hidden at the
bottom of this lake the original country
of guano as it turns out the strange
geography of wano is in fact artificial
the giant walls that come out of the
ocean were erected by some unknown power
that blocked wano from the outside world
800 years ago and so we now finally know
that the borders of wano were a very
literal thing all along that needed to
be opened the resultant basin with the
original country in it were then slowly
flooded by rain water over the next
centuries until the water started
spilling over the edges resulting in the
giant waterfalls that now you have to
climb up in order to get into the
country and honestly whatever mysterious
power erected those walls might very
well also be related to the creation of
the red line now the main reason that
wanos borders have been closed in other
words not broken down yet is because the
bottom of the lake harbors the ancient
weapon pluton that would be unleashed on
the worlds by tearing down these walls
this also explains why momonolsky can't
open juano's borders yet because he
clearly is aware of this fact and
connected to the weapon itself in fact
it pretty much fits perfectly into this
theory video on the ancient weapons that
i've made two weeks ago so if you want
to truly understand how pluton poseidon
and uranus actually work and what they
most likely look like you really can't
miss out on this video about it right
here